friends and neighbors have described the
Vlada checks as a nice normal family but
there's nothing normal about this
eleven-year-old Maya and her
three-year-old Brother David found dead
alongside their parents moniker and
Michael at home in West London
we're family friends their daughter
Jasmine at school with Maya I've got
pictures of where in my ass in same
outfit and then this morning she went
out
this is a shock I don't know how my
daughter is going to get through this
because they're very best mates
police were called to the flat near
Heathrow Airport on Friday afternoon
after concerns were raised over the
family's welfare officers had to force
their way in before they found the
bodies forensic experts have been
Gathering evidence ever since but they
still don't know what happened this
investigation is it a very early stage
but based on the initial inquiries
I can say that we are not currently
seeking anybody else in connection with
this very tragic incident
we must however retain an open mind as
to the circumstances
it's understood the family was polish
and had lived in the area for a number
of years
a school friend of Myers has told us
here that she had been trying to contact
her since Tuesday but she hadn't replied
to any messages and police are now
appealing to the local community to come
forward with any other information that
might help their investigation
whatever happened here has clearly been
deeply distressing for those who knew
the family extra officers will remain in
the area throughout the weekend a
community in need of support Ivor
Bennett Sky News Hounslow in West London